let's start with australia baseball how
big is the league how many teams are
there just walk us through the uh the
kind of league structure in the teams
yeah cool well there's eight teams in
the league and it's an international
competition so we've got a side also
from new zealand and also from korea
perth eight are the largest organization
uh in the australian baseball league
we've won 15 claxton shields and we've
had 11 players from the perth heat who
have gone on to play major league
baseball there's one currently uh
going around by the name of liam
hendricks who's with the chicago white
sox and he's just won reliever of the
year for the last two seasons which is
uh the first time that's happened in
major league baseball history uh we also
had graeme lloyd who won two
championships or two world series with
the new york yankees in 96 and also 1998
so baseball's big here in australia
we're ranked number six in the world uh
with team australia and uh yeah the
perth eight i'm pretty proud to be the
first team
in world sport now who are operating on
a bitcoin standard all right so you guys
are basically the new york yankees of uh
australia baseball is that a fair way to
think about it
essentially it depends who you want to
upset but yeah we'll take that yeah well
i said it you didn't say it so if they
get mad they got to get mad at me you're
the only team i talk to and the yankees
are the best so you must be the best
perfect
um all right so patrick the uh the the
thing that i got told you're the chief
bitcoin officer and when i said to my
brothers they said hey we need one of
those what the hell is a chief bitcoin
officer
exactly and you probably do need one of
those actually you might be the only
organization that doesn't need one right
you guys
you guys have already got it you guys
have been orange build uh really the
cheap bitcoin officer is someone you
know we've seen so beautifully what
michael saylor did with microstrategy
what he was able to do with the company
and what he was able to do with the
resources with that company when he
decided to go into the space he had all
these options of lawyers and accountants
and the whole thing that comes along
with a company of that size
the reality is there's a large number of
small companies that have identified the
space as something that they'd like to
be involved in they recognize maybe some
of the people involved in the leadership
team recognize some of the benefits that
might come from uh operating uh in the
bitcoin world but they just don't know
how to navigate it right it's an
ever-changing uh landscape both from the
infrastructure side of things to just
keeping up with what bitcoin is and the
way that it's being explained and the
way that people are learning about it
and basically the job that we have sort
of invented here with the cbo is i take
care of the educational side of things
like when we decided to make the move
you know steve and i had early
discussions in uh sort of 2019 early
2020 about this being a possibility um
and from there it was about educating
the board educating the leadership team
at the perth heat and then making sure
that when we actually decided yeah this
was a reality we could actually make
this work with what had been done uh
inside the bitcoin community and the
infrastructure that had been built up
behind it uh we could actually do it
then it was about coming on and
consulting with the partners in the
space to make sure that we were putting
ourselves in the best possible position
to leverage the most out of not only uh
bitcoin and the number go up technology
but also the network side of things and
how that was going to make the
organization more efficient so really
it's about education and it's also about
can you orange build somebody if you can
orange bill somebody um and you're
halfway decent at it it's probably
you're probably in line to be a ceo okay
so i want to talk about specifically
what you guys have done i talk all the
time about michael sailors taking his
balance sheets plugging it into the
bitcoin network the country of el
salvador is taking their entire country
they're plugging it into the bitcoin
network in a multitude of ways what i
apparently is happening here is you guys
are taking a professional baseball team
and you're plugging it into the bitcoin
network which when people first hear
that they're like that sounds insane
like who are these guys are they just
like religious zealots right and they've
got no clue what they're doing and
they're like speculating uh or do they
actually have a plan behind it so
stephen maybe talk a little bit about
from a tactical standpoint what exactly
are you guys doing along the lines of
plugging the baseball team into the
bitcoin network
yeah we think the sports revolution has
begun and unlike other sports deals that
we've seen in the crypto space
this is not a piecemeal announcement
uh perth heat are all in and this is
from the top down so we'll now hotel
bitcoin on our balance sheet uh we have
bitcoin payments for merchandise tickets
and memberships our payments to players
and staff are now in bitcoin
from this weekend inside the ballpark
you'll be able to come in and buy a hot
dog with bitcoin
um yeah we could have easily gone for
the cash and grab um sell fan tokens
efts and made a stack of cash pretty
quickly but we'll just become another
[ __ ] coin now this is where we are
different we are the bitcoin baseball
team and when i shoot coin sports team
as a as an amazing like literally
that was great uh all right and so when
you think about this what has been the
hardest part for you guys is it
convincing leadership to do it is it
actually technically implementing the
solutions needed to be able to process
and kind of support this idea or is it
something to do with the players and
getting their heads wrapped around it
uh probably some some of the issues we
faced
and the trepidation we had um was why is
nobody else doing this uh why are we
going to become the first team and once
we were able to overcome those hurdles i
guess the next question patrick and i
faced was
how are we now going to fund the team
because
by taking this position of the bitcoin
baseball team
how is mainstream media going to frame
us and was this going to upset members
fans and even some of our commercial
partners so when we thought about you
know what jack did with strike and the
indy 500 that was quite phenomenal
but patrick and i had to ask ourselves a
question continually is the bitcoin
community ready to support or fund a
baseball team now patrick and i feel
with you know by partnering with
like-minded companies moving forward
that is the best approach
the the greatest part that we've got you
know with the perth 8 is that we are
actually controlling the levers and the
network will guide us so in terms of an
organization we're pretty small you know
we're less than 100 employees our
operating costs would be like 50 bitcoin
so now we would like to partner with the
like-minded companies for example
bitcoin exchanges bitcoin miners
hardware software companies who support
the same values as we have and who would
like to pay partnerships in bitcoin only
why
because
that's how the community and the network
wins yeah say we huddle
50 bitcoin this season
next season we only need 30 bitcoin and
then the year after in 2024 we only need
10 bitcoin again why
because the perpetuity of those
sponsorships
will support perth heat forever and
again perth eight will win but more
importantly the bitcoin community will
win and this will be the future of sport
yeah
patrick when you think about what you
guys are doing uh what's so fascinating
to me is microstrategy kind of broached
the topic of public companies putting
bitcoin on their balance sheet we saw a
couple of come it's not a ton but a
couple more tesla square a bunch of kind
of bitcoin miners et cetera put bitcoin
on the balance sheet hold it there and
be proud of it talk about it as a
strategy el salvador obviously uh being
kind of the first country really put a
flag in the ground so we're gonna plug
our country in we anticipate there will
be others that follow uh here shortly
throughout central and south america is
this idea that like you guys are the
first to do this and there will be more
teams that will follow have you gotten
other phone calls from people saying hey
look you know we want to do this how'd
you do it what's been the reaction
absolutely that has probably been the
biggest thing that steve and i were not
anticipating getting into this is yeah
it's a big deal for the for the perth
heat but for the bitcoin network like
again we're just plugging in like we're
not coding any of this stuff as you say
we uh steve went once he made the
decision to say okay uh this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna go down this
line of action he hired everyone that
works for the bitcoin network to improve
the perth heat right there out there uh
making these things happen yourself
michael saylor all of these individuals
that are doing it and in that process of
figuring out okay well how is this
actually going to work from an
operational standpoint you get into
contact with different partners in the
space and you start to hear whispers and
we have since the announcement we have
been inundated basically with the
playbook like okay michael saylor had
the playbook on this is how you do it at
the corporate level but like i say at
the small business level at the
organization's under-hunted employees
like what does this actually look like
and we've just been uh completely
surprised about how many people are
interested in doing this how many people
where this is sort of even the people
that we spoken to in person like the the
sponsors that were already with the team
it's almost like you see the relief on
their face when you say
this is what we're doing this is why
we're doing it this is why it's going to
make us more efficient and better today
you know not some time in the future
this works right now um and you you see
that relief on their face and you see
that interest in that intrigue of like i
didn't even know this was possible let
alone going all in on this thing you
know people hear certain things and uh
the media frames bitcoin still in a
certain light
but it has been amazing to see just the
tsunami of activity behind the scenes of
people reaching out going okay who did
you partner with how did you do it
because like you know the the
infrastructure's changing all the time
where we could have gone our own and we
talked about this during uh you know the
lead up to the announcement it's like
what was what were we going to do from
an operational standpoint were we going
to try and be a completely
self-sovereign uh company where uh we
did all of the back end all that kind of
stuff or were we going to try and
partner up with someone uh like an open
note or someone like that to be able to
immediately jump on this right and get
the benefits of being first and trying
to lead the way um and ultimately we
decided to that would probably be the
best course of action is to jump in uh
you know start by walking and then uh
run as soon as we can and you can do
that from the front we've seen lots and
lots of just education on our own part
since we started to see how far this is
coming to see what works and what
doesn't work and see the little trips
and already we are leaps and bounds
ahead of anyone who is trying to come
behind us but we but we have been
encouraged by the amount of responses of
people that are interested in doing it
that have thought about doing it um and
you know people look to sports just like
you know we've seen announcements from
players like aaron rodgers sequon
barkley russell those guys uh people
look to sports for
inspiration they're used to looking up
to athletes they're used to looking to
see what they're doing and taking
inspiration from them and you know
hopefully we've been able to provide
that at the perth heat and i know
from a fact you're just looking at my
sort of twitter dms that people are
interested in it and uh and they want to
reach out and want to know more not only
is this cool but did you hear what
patrick just said to me he said i worked
for them now
he said yeah you work for us now thank
you
what questions you guys got for the
beauty